We had a deal, I get to be there when you take him down
I'm not going to kill him, I'm gonna make him wish he was dead
Prometheus knows who we all are
He knows that i'm the Green Arrow
I know everything
Who you love, who you trust, who you've hurt.
evelyn, why?
This city needs to be saved, from you!
Hey everybody Oliver versus Prometheus fight
night going down next week so let's break
it down.
Also some news about live-action teen Titans,
and there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway.
All you have to do to enter that flash ring
giveaway is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video.
Make sure you click that bell to enable alerts
so you don't miss out on anything if it wasn't
clear before it is definitely clear now that
that is Worf doing the voice for Prometheus
Michael Dorn which I totally loved and he
speaking so much more now, the kind of threaded
that end of the season like first we heard
him say he was Prometheus it almost didn't
sound like Michael Dorn, but the more you
speak in recent episodes like it just absolute
confirmed it like you could not tonight yet
that definitely sounds like Worf getting ready
to crush someone I told you to stay away from
the green green arrow found me.
So the whole theme of this trailer is kind
of the theme of the first half of the season.
This is the midseason finale.
So the closing down the set up of Oliver being
the villain of arrow season five at least
in the eyes of Prometheus and now Artemis
because you basically see Prometheus here,
just trying to torment him because of something
that he did in the past like Prometheus was
created because of something that Oliver did
in season one now we know it's because of
the list.
It looks like he's in some broken down office
building.
So maybe this is in the Glade somewhere it
just sounds like Prometheus was related to
or had a business in the Glades maybe he was
tied up in the undertaking or had family members
tied up in it.
That was going to make the city better at
least Merlin and his cabal thought that that
would make the city better, but Oliver wasn't
having it and then for the next like couple
seasons we had all out assault on the city
like things almost got worse.
So even though people like Artemis only started
hitting Oliver recently Prometheus has been
in training this whole time, since season
one to do what he's doing this season, to
Oliver and his friends.
So I like the way they cut this where they
liked splice Prometheus in like he's secretly
watching everyone whether walking like you
see his reflection pop up next Oliver to see
his shadow pop up next to Felicity's boyfriend,
throwing a little bit of water on the idea
that he's Prometheus, but when you look at
in here like hunched over this table claiming
his weapons.
He has a giant back like he looks like a huge
dude, which makes they want to cross a lot
of people off the list and I know that Colton
Haynes has like a pretty big back like he's
pretty Jacked but I don't think he's this
big he's not bigger than Stephen Amell.
So even though I'm not expecting Kovar Dolph
Lundgren from the flashbacks to be the villain
of present-day I feel like this person is
from Star city Prometheus is somebody from
the city that Oliver trashed while he was
trying to save it Kovar is just one of the
few people who is big enough to fit this profile
here whoever he is he's meant to be more than
a physical match for Stephen Amell and there
can have like a bad ass knockdown drag out
fight, it's the midseason finale.
So they save the biggest reveals like if you
member deathstroke was revealed in the midseason
finale during season two they shall cool almost
kill Oliver.
Now he is going to have it out with Prometheus.
So even Stephen Amell's been posting pictures
from behind-the-scenes some of the stunts
that they're going to be doing.
But you young justice fans out there will
look at this Artemis storyline her, but train
the team and think about sports master stuff
going on Prometheus is not her father.
They did explain how long she's been working
with Prometheus.
It is not been this whole time.
They said it was around episode six where
the team found out about the list.
It was like between act breaks and they'll
got super pissed off, and it almost seem like
team arrow was can a break up that was the
moment that she decided to work with Prometheus.
So it hasn't been for that long young justice
Artemis was the daughter of two villains sports
master and huntress.
So she rebelled by trying to be good.
But they kept pulling at her trying to get
her to turn on the team.
So we might see some flip-flopping from Artemis
like she wants to believe in the team she's
not completely evil she just things that Oliver
is evil like she says the city needs to be
saved from you big shocking twist.
So there a couple different ways that that
could go down one Oliver could convince her
that he's trying to do the right thing and
shall come around and rejoin the team eventually
to shall be the tragic character that Prometheus
will kill just to torment Oliver, so that's
one more body on his conscience like Prometheus
says he doesn't want to kill Oliver he just
wants to torment him to prolong his sorrow
as much as possible so look at this freaky
chart here then look at Mr. terrific getting
his ass handed to him like he doesn't look
like he's dead.
It just looks like Prometheus puts him in
the hospital and then look at the chart again
and see the big X through Quentyn.
So, I know that makes it seem like he's dead,
but it's probably just Prometheus putting
him down for the count cc all these of the
people he's going after.
I would not be surprised if there's at least
one major death before the end of the season
and I think that Artemis is at the top of
that list, so let me know in the comments.
If Prometheus ends up killing anybody that's
on his list here like his reverse version
of the list.
Do you think that Artemis is going to be the
one to get the shaft, but even though that
sounds like a bit of a bummer, it's good to
get pretty crazy now that were moving into
the back half of the season that moment in
the big crossover episode the Arrow 100th
episode from last night where Oliver saw.
Although shadow saw Tommy, so his parents
saw a Roy they were reassuring him that he
was a good person doing the right thing giving
him that bump he needed to continue his mission
the past that his father set him on with the
list like it all started with the list on
the island.
It just that Oliver's methods have changed
over time not the mission the mission is the
same.
So what I'm expecting is is less indecisiveness
from Oliver like he's fully committed like
he knows he's doing the right thing, so he's
just going to hard charge Prometheus and throw
down big time.
So if you are your friends haven't been watching
arrow this season now is the time to jump
back on because were doing Talley all cool
in the back half of the season and Laurel
is coming back some big twist.
I have no idea what it's gonna look like they've
only said that Laurel is coming back she's
alive and well.
They didn't say with.
The twist is or what that's gonna look like
or what the dynamic with the group is going
to be or she's going to be doing black canary
stuff and Artemis dying, I know that would
be a bummer for live-action teen Titans potential
but just to talk about that.
So Andrew Kreisberg one of the big producers
in this arrow universe he's mostly working
on Supergirl, but he also created the flash
TV show he kind of runs both shows he is like
a lifelong hard-core teen Titans fan, but
when people ask him what his favorite title
is it's always teen Titans.
So the fact that they have most of the teen
Titans or even young justice cast means that
they'll probably try to develop something
like that in the future.
They're all about the big team ups.
Now they get double the ratings.
When they do stuff like this.
So it makes sense they try to do something
like that when arrow eventually goes off the
air, but let me know what you guys want live-action
teen Titans.
They have the Hall of Justice now.
So they have to do teen Titans at some point
and for those you that keep asking about the
TNT live-action teen Titans.
They were originally developing a Titans show
that died last year so it's no longer in development
at TNT the people that were working on that
aren't working on it anymore.
Meaning that it's free for other people to
turn into a show, but the other really cool
thing that just happen all talk about this
more.
We get more information but Warner Bros. and
DC comics is working on a digital subscription
service like HBO now just for DC comics movies
and TV shows that the talking about animated
stuff to talk about the live-action movies
they're talking about stuff like the CW, TV
shows, but because they're just starting to
make young justice season three it's gonna
take a little while to finish what they might
do is use that digital subscription service
to launch that so it some point in the future
in the next year or two you'll be able to
like subscribe to a digital subscription service.
It is just, comic book stuff and on the flipside
of that Disney is thinking about doing the
exact same thing with Marvel and Star Wars
content.
So if you like a lot of people like pay a
bunch of extra money, just because they want
that one channel like you just want HBO or
you just want to get the comic book stuff
eventually you be able to do that without
having to spend like a ton of extra money
so next on the trying get that Rick and Morty
season three video out then we have the last
night of the crossover on legends tonight
so that video will post tonight if I don't
think I'm in a get Rick and Morty out then
I'll just post that tomorrow and there is
some Spider-Man homecoming stuff that's coming
tomorrow.
So get hype all remind all you guys about
that when I post my legends video later tonight
While you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for my Arrow 100th episode video
and you can click here for the trailer for
next week's flash episode thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll see
you guys tonight!